sept jours après son démarrage opération
paris plage attire toujours autant de
monde et pas seulement dans la journée
le soir après le travail beaucoup de
parisiens vont ils faire un petit tour
pour goûter à l'ambiance guinguette et à
quelque chose qui pourrait ressembler à
des vacances reportage soares nikov et
bernard connor il y à bien une vie après
le travail
oublier la grisaille le costard étriquée
des piles de dossiers un peu de sport ça
fait pas de mal
paris plage ça commence au pied de
l'hôtel de ville un peu plus loin tandis
que les uns rongent leur frein en
voiture ça fout de bureaux vij les
autres se sont empressés de trouver une
place au chaud sur le stable tendez
l'oreille bon pour les vagues
il faut encore un effort mais la vue
vaut bien le déplacement
c'est fabriqué pour
on est divisé
ici le soir de la musique des spectacles
on en trouve tous les sens mais les
artistes de rue s'en donnent à coeur
joie
on a troqué la terrasse pour les nappes
à carreaux
histoire de partager un bon repas et
plus si affinités la soirée commence et
c'est anigo rencontre ben de charmantes
personnes autour c'est serré dans le siv
est assez facile en parfait géo la
mairie de paris a prévu sur la plage une
centaine d'événements pour l'été pour
les insomniaques hyperactif la troupe du
bal des perceptions les convie un
spectacle à dormir debout les jambes
plus vraiment envie de me fondre dans
celle est autrement de reparcourir la
ville autrement est mélangé les deux
c'est un gagneur et du soin des clous
passif est très bon nuit et jour la
sécurité est assurée seul ou en famille
chacun de s'offrir ici des vacances d'un
soir au stade